but through some stuff that he hasn't
even told me because he's like it's too
much grab a snack and get ready because
Shane Dawson just dropped part 1 of his
new series the beautiful world of
jeffree star which shows off Jeffrey's
luxurious and sometimes scary lifestyle
why is it so yeah it's like here's what
we've learned so far
Shayne's journey with jeffrey starts in
february 2019 with a 24-hour trip to
Sacramento where the beauty mogul is
making a guest appearance at Murphy's
store openings
yeah so normally I travel with my own
bodyguard always so I Drive a second one
for you
Jeffrey who boasts over 14 million
followers online reveals he doesn't ever
travel without his security and they're
always armed
[Music]
1% chance they shoot
because he needs the backup
controversies aside his fans are next
level jeffrey star stands
[Music]
[Applause]
No I wish I could finally just find all
the docu-series is chronicling Jeffry
and Shane's journey of creating a makeup
line together and sometimes fan behavior
can seemingly get out of hand
just letting you know anything is
launched people are going to ruin it
they're gonna leak it they're gonna try
to expose you they're gonna try to like
make it pay you so don't buy your makeup
they're gonna try to do anything they
can like other companies to ruin your
thing like that I mean it was like in
the first episode which was filmed in
February we see that Jeffery is still
friends with James Charles because all
that taught to Westbrook James drama
didn't happen until May well most likely
see some of the behind the scenes of
what went down during and after the fall
out but whether Shane takes part in the
drama is yet to be seen
oh wait yeah this isn't a game anymore
speaking of fallout Jeffrey addresses
that infamous middle finger pick that
went viral and made him quote genuinely
sad backstory fellow beauty bloggers
Laura Lee Gabriel Zamora mani MUA and
Nikita Dragon all former friends of
Jeffrey shared this pic on social media
seemingly flipping him off stating
they're doing better without him
a picture have the Internet and topic it
would happen we spent you know a few
years together a lot of the time
inseparable I think why I was so hurt
you know because I wasn't there wasn't a
fake friendship it was so real it was
crazy the situation we're totally cool
he came over to my house he apologized
man-to-man I think it's a great guy
though Blake
bish I'm over it now we also see Shane
and Jeffrey bond over their anxiety and
although the public may believe Jeffrey
has a cocky persona he says it's all a
facade that cocky attitude that I can
like pretend sometimes to have that but
that's not me like I'm Pacific and
reveals he's not always confident in his
decisions when it comes to his brand
admitting he had career regrets I got a
lot of backlash from some parts of the
beauty community and it actually made me
insecure and I was like whoa like did I
make a mistake like I believe in this so
strongly but like people are making me
feel weird and like I didn't feel proud
for a minute I fully cried it was like
so nervous I even cried to Nicola it's
like Nicole like did I make the wrong
choice when it comes to his beauty
routine Jeffery gets a full glam thanks
to influencer and besties lipstick Nick
and he doesn't put on lipstick until
he's at an event another discovery
fellow youtuber Jojo siwash shares
Jeffrey's expensive tastes
curiously watches me
my god yeah please not yes yes
if the teaser is any indication there's
going to be a lot of drama in this nine
part docu-series you're nice but naive
and it's time to change that we'll see
the intricacies of Jeffries Empire and
how Shane becomes a part of it as they
work on creating their makeup line it's
almost like
[Music]
[Applause]